Narrator: THE MULTI-TOOL.
IT'S A TOOLBOX
THAT FITS IN YOUR POCKET,
ONE TOOL THAT DOES MORE
THAN JUST ONE JOB.
HOW DOES THIS 8 1/2-INCH PIECE
OF METAL
TRANSFORM
INTO SO MANY DIFFERENT TOOLS?
UNDER A TEMPERED STEEL FRAME...
17 DIFFERENT TOOLS
DEPLOY WITH A SIMPLE FLICK.
THREE SETS OF SAFETY TABS
LOCK THEM INTO PLACE.
A CLEVER HINGE
HOLDS THE TOOLS TOGETHER
AND ALLOWS FOR
A TRADEMARK TRANSFORMATION
FROM A MULTI-TOOL
TO A PAIR OF PLIERS
WITH A FLICK OF THE WRIST.
17 DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS
TO THOUSANDS
OF DIFFERENT PROBLEMS.
THIS MULTI-TOOL GIVES YOU
RAZOR-SHARP BLADES
IN THE PALM OF YOUR HAND.
SO EACH TOOL MUST HAVE
A DEDICATED SAFETY MECHANISM.
THE HINGES OF THE LONG BLADES...
CLICK INTO
TEMPERED STEEL CATCHES.
ON THE OTHER SIDE,
T-SHAPED TABS SECURE THE BASES
OF THE SHORTER TOOLS.
AND IN THE PLIER FORMATION,
HIDDEN WEDGES PUSH OUT A PIN
TO LOCK DOWN THE BLADES
ON THE INSIDE.
THEY RELEASE
WHEN YOU CLOSE THE PLIERS
SO YOU CAN GET ON WITH
THE NEXT JOB.
THE INGENIOUS POCKET TOOLBOX,
17 TOOLS
IN ONE 4-INCH HANDLE,
GETS THOUSANDS
OF OUTDOOR ADVENTURERS
OUT OF THE TIGHTEST OF SPOTS.
WHY WOULD YOU EVER
LEAVE HOME WITHOUT IT?